- [Narrator] Here's how I
prepare for my coding interview.
I solve 1,513 leetcode problems.
Memorize all of the answers,
read "Cracking the Coding
Interview" five times,
read "Elements of Programming Interviews"
in all three languages.
Python, C++ and Spanish.
Read "Grokking the
Systems Design Interview."
Don't understand shit,
but memorize every keyword.
Sharding, caching, load balancing.
Damn, I'm so smart.
Go on LinkedIn to stalk my interviewer.
Check their Facebook,
check their Twitter,
check their Wife.
Hm. Nice.
Go on on Glassdoor to find
the interview questions they ask.
Not good enough.
Pay lots of money to access
a sketchy Chinese website
to get leaked interview questions.
Perfect.
I go to the bathroom
for my breathing exercise.
Fucking love meditating.
The company is calling
me for an interview,
I bring up all my cheat sheets.
This is child's play.
I'm ready for this.
- Hey, thank you so much
for hopping on this call.
- You're welcome.
- Yeah, OK.
So, I'm your interviewer.
And yeah, so the first question is
what would you do if you had a conflict
with your manager?
- Hashmap, I'll use a Hashmap!